or no
yeah of course you're still staying the
same thing what have i been saying
sons i didn't say the songs would you
say miami heat you know if you can stick
to my video yeah of course
she's still got a chat we're live okay
we're officially live folks uh
i think it's fair to say we miss you i
have to tell you i miss you it's been
too long
it's it's been a week it's we miss you
so much that adam's still playing the
ads in the background i apologize but
it's good to be back fellas adam yes
tom yes uh we've been away last week we
decided to take a long vacation just
traveling how was italy
i got to know the people in sicily were
fantastic it's incredible
we had a good time it's a we had a very
very good time we'll see what's going to
happen what was your favorite part the
the pasta the dishes was ridiculous
unbelievable
the food there next time you go to italy
maybe you take some friends i don't even
want to tell you stories of it i don't
even want to tell you stories of it
the sicilian people are very i don't
even want to tell you stories of what
happened but it's going to be welcoming
people yes it's going to be interesting
it's amazing
well it's good to be back first of all
we got a lot of crazy stories but the
one story i thought it was important for
us to start off with this
i think you needed an inspiration i
think i think like adam i was thinking
about
what would motivate adam yeah and
there's a man in
in india that i think could be adam's
tony robbins you take it where you can
get can you put the story up please i
think it's a very important story that
just was
introduced and by the way maybe father
of 89 kids
world's largest family dead at 76 in
india
can you imagine at 76 years old the guy
has 89 kids
okay do you think that record will be
broken
89 kids i mean you think someone's gonna
pull off a world chamberlain and get a
hundred kids i mean do the math i mean
you gotta have a triplets every year
no wonder india's got one and a half
billion people i mean at this pace
they're going to be at 10 billion in no
time like people are getting inspired by
population yeah here's his biggest
problem how many ex-wives does he have
holy crap i mean that system say that
again
kai we can't hear you gotta hit the a
lot of child support but do we actually
know how many wives he has or no like
how how many
[ __ ] that took at least 10
women there's not at least 10 women you
think so
yeah i want to know the over under at
least what do you mean each k each woman
was having nine kids of her own
i think there was like 15 20 women dude
listen
everybody's claiming like warren betty's
the biggest player or will chamberlain
this guy's gotta what's his name like
yeah but you noticed he's the only one
not smiling can we read the reporting
most prolific father in the world the
pastor
knows china was a head of a polygamist
oh 38 wives
okay got it 38 38 wives there we go 89
children 36 grandchildren making them
buy some reports the head of the world's
largest family during his lifetime with
heavy heart
mushroom but with over to mr around
believe their head world starts on
89 kids yeah yeah he died 76.
well i mean he's sitting there thinking
about
he's sitting there thinking about 89
kids he's got to take care of
here's a question yeah over under on how
many of his own kids names
he remembered i'm saying 50 percent
maybe 50.
i think after 10 kids he called them
numbers yeah
11. how you doing i did the whole one
hey
64. hey good
[Laughter]
you know george is worth 400 million
that grill was good for him i think it's
worth it yeah i think good for him yeah
that he's worth 400 million i think it's
a
great success story but anyways i wanted
to kind of uh motivate you a little bit
thank you thank you
that's phony robins right there that
story would have inspired motivated so
if you start now it might only take you
about 50 or 60 years yeah i gotta get
another couple dozen women in my uh
profile and
it's gonna be we're back to business
gonna be in him but can you imagine
having that many kids though
like what is 89 kids what is the outcome
of that to have that many kids
if someone had told me what the world or
asked me what the world record is i
would say 30.
but 89 that that's unfortunate you know
what is an impressive record though
what's the most kids a person's had with
the same
partner that's what's an impressive
record to me probably in the 20s
it's like someone's under four i don't
think you 20
do 30 and it's got to be more than the
teens it's in the 20 somewhere
so you're saying the same woman giving
birth yes yes i believe it happened
same mom and dad what's the most you
know the most i know is 15.
i'd have to say 12. i don't know if i
know anybody that higher that much
higher
what's the most you know four no yeah i
mean you're about to have a fourth baby
so that's a lot you're like number one
for me right now
this guy's got three you got four i got
two cats next thing you know we got a
polygamy fan
the challenge is to be able to manage
two cats that's difficult
that's it that's a job talent
challenging uh job out there but
someone's got to do it okay
i've got six women helping me raise two
cats it's tough out there oh listen did
you send your birthday card yesterday or
no i know you're like uh
donald trump yeah yes you did i had some
arson in it it was not a big deal but uh
happy birthday donald
trump yeah driven down there and just
had lunch with him yeah well it was
funny because when we were doing the
thing of the breakers i drove by
mar-a-lago multiple times i give a i
gave a wave there's a big american flag
there respect
yeah i do love america he loves america
too you know
some people might say that but he loves
a different america than america you
love he loves the mega crowd he loves uh
i like just normal people
yeah that's good a lot of your normal
are becoming weird nowadays
they're so very very well and i think
with that being said let's just go into
that story
i think that's the story to get into so
look typically we're going to a
bunch of random stuff we got a lot of
crazy stories travels back at two
million people a day according to tsa
which is fantastic news
if you want to take a flight to space
with jeff bezos you can do it for 28
million bucks
is it even worth it by the way to 20
million bucks you know i can mix when we
get to that story i'll tell you what
they're going to do
it's interesting for someone it
definitely is worth 28 million if you're
a billionaire here's a question if
you're worth a billion would you spend
2.8 percent of your what
wealth to go to space if i love you you
would if i loved it that much
space enthusiasm i'm asking you though
would you
do you have any desire to go to space
yeah i'm down
listen when you're that wealthy when
you're in the billionaire club
it's all about clout but what i'm asking
you is at what because to me it's all a
percentage conversation that's all it is
what percentage of your wealth are you
willing to spend to go into space
what percentage yeah do you know what
i'm saying you understand what i'm
asking
you like meaning if you're 280 million
dollars cash would you spend 10
of it if you're a billion dollars would
you spend two point eight percent of it
at what percentage are you willing to
say i'll go
10 okay so at 280 you would say yes to
it i'd say yeah
exactly that's interesting a gambling
number
i don't even know if i'd want to go to
space okay so that's the question
whether you'd want to go or not how
about you have no desire to go into this
race at all but if somebody said
hey would you want to take a private jet
and go to the nba finals the world
series the olympics the super bowl in
one year
i'd do ten percent oh would you now go
to space what would you spend let me ask
you a question folks you're listening to
this
you're worth a billion dollars matter of
fact forget about you're worth a billion
dollars
would you spend 28 of your wealth to go
into space
thumbs up if you would thumbs down if
there's no way in the world you could
care
less about going into space right now
we're at 60 zero let's see what the
ratios are going to be
let me tell you why it's it's a big deal
tell me because you know when you enter
that billionaire class it's all about
clout
i got the richest this i got the biggest
boat i got the fastest car
yeah i got the ducati whatever whatever
it is that you
are chasing with the cloud-chasingness
yeah now you're going to freaking space
bro
what or you could say is that even was
that even a thing ever on anyone's mind
yeah
now you get to go to space even if it's
for 11 minutes apparently it's overrated
it's 11 minutes are we talking about
this story
are we holding it let's go right into it
right now you also could be the only
billionaire
to die when your parachute doesn't open
there's a one percent
please jesus christ you know what it's
cheese and rest tom
if we're on this topic wouldn't it be
interesting to know who the guy is they
haven't figured it out yet they haven't
announced it yet so 28 million he paid
in this elect in this auction i say it's
richard branson would that be the
ultimate
publicity stunt ever he hops on board
bezos's ship there's only one bigger
publicity stunt if it's elon musk that
did it
boom we got roommates going on hilarious
do you think you think you're beating me
to space because that's the whole thing
space next thing you know elon shows up
you like speed
i uh uh i think i would be very curious
to do it um kids are under
10. i'd probably do it if they were
above if the youngest was
above 14 they had plenty of the dad they
need i would probably do that no that's
that's probably how it works
your factor in risk and factoring in the
value of a father figure in a kid's life
after 14 if i die they got plenty out of
me if they screw up after that's on them
why 14. i think that's a good agent at
that point you're gonna
at that point i listen to your parents
anyways you're gonna do whatever the
hell you want to do so
if i've taught you whatever i taught you
until 14 you want to do whatever you
want to do if it didn't work you know
what my teaching stuff i think i'll move
on think about a path they have hundreds
of hours of your videos yeah to
absorb you the rest of their life anyway
you know but dude
hey basil's was brilliant how he did
this because this capsule is cool
two-thirds of it is windows right so
it's all set up for
for future tourism so that's the whole
idea
so so what they're going to do is
they're going to go straight up they're
going to hit a speed of 2 300 miles an
hour which is three times the speed of
sound like that okay so it burns off all
the fuel it can't go any higher
so i think it's about 64 miles up in the
air that's where you kind of enter this
space area
so then they're going to be weightless
then they take off the seat belt they
can float around for about two minutes
and then they can take their pictures
and they're going to look throughout the
windows they're going to see earth
they're going to see the round earth in
the background and then they come down
and then they
they're thrown out with parachutes
that's how they're getting down and
they're going to land in the west texas
desert
20 miles an hour is what they're be
hitting the ground at about with these
parachutes so
you know they've done it many many times
without humans so this is the first time
and by the way nasa has calculated
when you go into space there's a one
percent chance you die based on how many
space flights we've had and how many
people have died in space so
it's a lot riskier than going up in a
plane it's a total ego boost for whoever
is doing this
it would be cool i guess if you do
survive i just don't have i don't need
thrills i'm i'm not that guy
that's looking to you know go into space
and come on back down
on earth one percent is that bad if it's
one percent i may actually
do it today if it was a one percent
chance one percent i would do it
i would do it if it's one percent 28
million bucks yeah yeah
it is it is definitely something on you
can imagine you go for a job interview
so what can you put us what you have
only one thing you've done in your life
tell us about the last year of your life
forget haagen-dazs i know it's
impressive forget burger king forget
about the fact that i was in morgan
stanley military ballets sorry
i went to space with jeff bezos hey
here's the question we should have asked
dr
mike customer service head of customer
service that's why you didn't do the
podcast last week because we would have
said
house space which one are you picking i
chose the house
good call as of last week
congratulations i appreciate you know
that you announced that
i'm excited about it for someone that is
not interested in doing space whatsoever
and isn't interested in the thrills
tom zenner certainly knows every
freaking detail of what's going on with
his face
i think deep down inside he wants to go
yeah but i think he's also looking at
he's got kids
and he wants us to do whatever she's
going to sign the permission slip i want
to go to space shuttle sorry honey you
can't go we're not signing i'm not going
to do it
she she's actually very very powerful
okay and
you want to retract that statement or
because she's going to hear it next five
three
said she's not done growing she's almost
five she's not done growing
she pulled down hope so here's here's
the the next question yeah because
obviously there's you said one percent
risk jeff bezos is going to space with
his brother and
whoever this 28 million dollar winner of
the auction is
respect i don't know who it is they
haven't announced it yet
obviously the the the 99 chance that
everything will be okay let's talk about
that one percent chance how much life
insurance do you think jeff bezos has
how much estate planning
do you think he's done do you think he's
got a billion dollars of life insurance
and nobody gets that much the reason why
i know he doesn't have a billion dollars
of insurance because the record of the
biggest policy sold was 210 million
dollars some number like that that went
to guinness
so but no one knows who the 210 was some
say speculated was bill gates some say
was uh
one of those buffett or bill gates so i
know he doesn't have billion dollars of
insurance
but at this point of the game you know
insurance at that level
yeah you know you're worth a couple
hundred billion dollars yeah his
insurance is he still owns
amazon his insurance is a lobbyist his
insurance is working with dc his
insurance is washington post that's his
insurance policy
to make sure the estate taxes don't go
against him et cetera et cetera that's
his insurance policy yeah anyway so in
this at this table
you're not going i'm going you would go
i'm in i would go
kai's not going so you guys would run
the podcast we'd be out there hanging
out with jeff
let's see what happens 56 million budget
we could we could raise that kind of
money i got an idea speaking of that 99
one percent i'll put down one percent
down payment you take care of the rest
of the 99 percent of the 28 million your
level we got a deal
we got a deal yeah i got to tell you i
feel like we can meet halfway
or 99 or semi genius there's i don't
care what anybody says about you in the
comment section you're you're genius
well here's the problem he gets 10
of the parachute right yeah what i would
do we would do the one person
99 but you get to sit outside so you got
like a view from the outside it's even
2500 can you imagine the whole what do
you call it when the lips come back we
see that's like when we were going to
fly
we lost adam there's a parachute in
space but doesn't mean
in space there's no gravity so he just
keeps going and going and going and
often you
run into a land in a in a
a place where it's like earth and aliens
fall in love with you and adam becomes
the king the ruler of that planet yeah i
mean
king sauce yep and he has 90 kids king
sauce new nickname no more soy boy king
sauce breaks the community might get
upset all right let's see what we got
okay so apparently tom
is really emotionally attached to the
clay travis story with the
same boobs and uh first amendment and uh
whatever happened with jeffrey tobin
on uh the zoom who got caught was he
publicly
did he actually was it like live when he
was or no he was tubing that thing
he zoomed or his cnn colleagues saw it
it was either cnn or the new yorker that
he was on the meeting with but no they
saw it yeah for sure they said they saw
him masturbating
while he's doing the zoom with his
colleagues yes yeah
and then they fired him and they brought
him back right but clay travis got fired
because he said the only two things i
trust is in the first amendment and boom
boobs
yeah what do you think about that what
do you think about that story
what's the story here go go to it i'm
gonna go to page four
you know he got canned by the new york
uh
but his other job he got canned but cnn
brought him back after seven months he
said he went to therapy what kind of
therapy do you go to
after masturbating on zoom i mean is
there some sort of special
camp you go to to learn not to do that i
know billions of people that need to go
to therapy
that business i got i got there's a big
business for it if it's uh
what they do is they tell them how to
adjust their camera right so they don't
like gosh
anyway um you know here's the problem
with it i like tubin's work
you know i do i should he be let back
i'm gonna say yes i said why not because
here's the i'm not surprised that he's
back at all because cnn caters to one
particular audience someone that
believes everything they say
he's part of that roster of course
they're going to bring him back
they're not going to make him pay a
price any more extensively than he has
to
you know he did the book on the o.j
simpson trial back in uh you know
i think in the early like around 2010
2011 that book came out
and that's what fx based that their
their special series on
um that oj series which was phenomenal
the one where david schwimmer played
robert kardashian john travolta
was robert shapiro i like his work you
know and i think cnn was smart to do it
because
their ratings are down 39 that's a scary
thing
39 down since trump you know left office
so
they've got to do anything they can to
get a little bit of mojo a little
publicity
and this helped them so i'm not shocked
they brought him back i kind of like
tubing i like his personality
and look would i come back if i did
something like that hell
no you wouldn't come back i mean i think
i just want to crawl under a rock
forever i think at that point you are so
shameless you could care less
probably you could care less listen yes
what do you want to do about it do you
want to hire me or no
i do what you do except i got caught on
camera you did it privately what do you
want to do with it
it's pretty embarrassing well i mean
what's the we watched the video of this
guy clay travis
look i don't understand the correlation
here like what
clay travis did i never heard of before
this thing and what to do you don't know
clay travis i don't know who that is
he's about to replace rush limbaugh
he's a sports he's like a imagine a dave
portnoy style except a more out
public gotcha supporter of a republican
idea well let me tell you something i
actually agree with his stance on uh
the first amendment and boobs i love the
first amendment i love that i could talk
about how much i love the first
amendment and i love that the fact that
the first and last amendment emotionally
connected
allows me to say that i love boobs too
okay i'm with you travis
so uh i i think i'm on team clay here
i'll i'll let my man zenner do his
little wank thing with tubing you can
get tubing with him on the left and the
right
and i'm just going to stick with clay
travis on the boobs if you want to
you know wow hang with uh very
impressive to see by the way shanda just
texted you she's probably going to tell
you get off the podcast right now
do the dishes so you're siding with clay
travis right that's what you're doing
i don't underst like the the shauna if
you're listening hello sean i'm looking
forward to seeing you
number one when this guy clay travis
basically appeared on the program that
was in 2017.
toobin was doing his thing in 2020
during the whole zoom
zoom-a-thon so i i don't tuban was an
actual
correspondent anchor where he had his
own
you know what's the thing though the way
cnn did it
to allow him to the lady lit did you see
the interview how she interviewed him
she's like um
she was shocked tuban let's just go in
it and and cover this here
first of all uh uh uh i think you're
pretty embarrassed of what you did
and she's putting words in she's like
feeding him the words
and and you know last year in zoom
while we were having the zoom when we
went off
your camera stayed on and when it stayed
on
you were can i say this you were
masturbating
yes i was and i'm extremely apologetic
to it and you know you should see how it
is like an apology
like so they were kind of helping him to
come back and redeem and gain fans but
you know for the rest of his life he's
going to be like
you know yeah is he is he part of the
crowd with who was that one
herman herman is he part of community
yeah yeah that's part of the community
probably bigger so i think we should
send them a pv herman shirt
we should send them a gift there it
shows you how stupid playhouse it really
really how stupid they are the smartest
thing that you can do which adam sitting
to your left the smartest thing they
could do is
keep clay travis on as a guest every now
and then because it would give them
something to talk about the rest
of them got fired clay travis got fired
i mean that was in 2017 yeah i don't
know like that's four years ago why is
that even news right now
well no no no clay travis is a smart
market or mated news that's what you
call a great market a credit to clay
travis
the fact that we're even covering this
is because he brought his story of 17
and made himself relevant with this to
say this guy didn't get fired but i got
fired because of one commentator oh he
put it out that's kind of how he put it
out there he
tweeted
yeah that makes sense what's the problem
with these extreme news all they are
are echo chambers that's all it is so of
course they're not going to have clay
travis on there because
even though it would be the smartest
thing they could possibly do by the way
here's what i want to do
there's so many crazy things that happen
with zoom my kids this weekend out of
all the movies that had a choice to
watch they chose to watch the movie with
what's the war with grandpa is that what
the movie's called have you seen war
with grandpa where robert de niro and
this kid are going back and forth
because
his daughter gave his son's room to him
and they're going at it and it's
each is playing pranks on the other one
it's hilarious what happens there right
and they paint
de niro to be like a made man mobster
he's got this driver all this stuff
during the zoom era i wonder how many
stupid stories
happen how many embarrassing things
happen kai do you have the one that you
just sent me with the judge
have you seen this what the guy goes to
court this one old man doesn't know how
to change the screensaver of his and the
judge keeps saying sir
watch this just watch this here
audio
watch this leave you have a filter
turned on
you might want to uh oh can you flip it
up can you hear me judge
the budget i
don't know how to remove it they're dead
serious here she's trying to
but i'm prepared to go forward with it
i guess i'm here live that's not i'm not
a cat
for the can you play one more time can i
point something out yeah go ahead
hit play this guy's tubanizing himself
right now
he's looking at something it's either a
phone or it's his tubing
did you hear me
do you really want to miss out on this
great opportunity to witness something
like this this is a gift right here to
the world
this is a gift right here by the way you
were talking about uh you know they're
talking about
go back to youtube i ran a search
yesterday go on youtube
and do me a favor take a look at this
take a look at this so let's look at
three different
media outlets give me the three biggest
news outlets that people follow the
three cnn
msnbc let's say cnn let's say fox
we're gonna play game we're gonna play
again you okay with this game uh adam i
like it again
cnn fox msnbc
okay kai i want you to go ty uh go to
uh msnbc's channel uh matter of fact
go to msnbc's channel just go to their
youtube channel yeah
go to their videos how did i do it
yesterday the way i did it oh
here's how i did it go to um
go to go to filters go with this
there's an n not an m m is mumbai yeah
n there you go got it okay go to this
week
and then go to views view count okay so
this is
the most viewed videos for msnbc in the
last week
let's see all the topics what they're
related to and what makes some money
okay first one is what mag trump second
one is what
trump third one is what trump fourth one
is what trump keep going down kai
fifth one is what trump sixth trump
seventh trump
eighth trump nine trump keep going ten
is trump 11 is trump mueller
12 is trump go 13
is trump go next one 14 is
the only one that is not trump so 13 out
of 13 is what
trump so we're going to put top 13 out
of 13 stories for msnbc's trump now
let's go to cnn let's see topics i'm
gonna put right here trump
what makes them money okay go to cnn do
the same exact searches go to
this week and then go to views let's see
what they got
okay so obama criticizes republicans for
embracing 2020 falsehoods do you want to
kind of say trump
i think that's kind of trump but i'll
let you pick and choose yes or no
obamacare course okay second one the
second one trump
no because that's brazil third one is
not trump
fourth one is not trump fifth one is
trump so so far hang on we got what two
out of five
no it's two out of five it's trump three
out of six keep going
it's not trump but that's not even
that's an ad so
three out of six gold then it's uh next
one is what this is unacceptable that's
not trump
uh that no that's not trump so so three
out of seven
bill bart is not trump so three out of
eight there's tom's friend
three out of nine go keep going keep
going keep going keep going keep going
not so three out of ten three out of 11.
uh probably 45
no so let's just say 4 out of 12. fair
enough by the way respect to cnn now go
to fox
so 4 out of 12 for them is trump but
msnbc is a hundred percent
anti-trump videos make them money now
let's go to fox news
kai type in fox news there's a lot of
different foxes you got to type in fox
news there you go okay
go to go to this week
oh my gosh i wonder how you search
sometimes okay all right so let's see
fox's stories take a look at fox's first
one is about what
okay is one so i'm going to give votes
you keep telling me
next one is about what the swallow
california representative
all right so next next
is the next one also kamala yep okay so
so four out of five is kamala
who's the next one right there telco
obtaining so the bias free so let's just
say yeah
not not anything uh
another kamala story another kamala keep
going another
china okay china one oc aoc
tucker story but what is it about the
tucker store this is everywhere
chronicle magazine pedro
okay let's just put american dream
different story tucker story give me
next one
uh california california next shelter
hunter biden stelter okay so check this
out check this out
check this out check this out so we'll
go 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 13. now watch this how many
stories were joe biden
0. okay joe biden doesn't make money
folks
period there is not a single joe biden
story
not msnbc not cnn not fox
because the current president is so
boring that media makes zero money
talking about him
they have to keep talking about msnbc's
business model
is trashing trump to make money 13 out
of 13. i mean it's not even like a
you know a fair he's got a monopoly
there and you know what else was
interesting is the views of the videos
msnbc
had some good views on on those trump
videos cnn didn't have one
view i don't think over a million and
fox had at least five or six that were
over a million including one that was
2.1 million
so it's actually working for msnbc
they're getting a lot of views cnn's not
even getting numbers
somebody's sitting there saying guys we
got to make sure we talk about
trump because that's what's getting
eyeballs and we got to get the eyeballs
to uh uh to to keep selling ads okay i
mean that's interesting to see that
so uh uh you're on clay travis's team
you're on uh um
the rest of the fact let me say
something about what's going on here so
you know breaking news the media is a
business it's like old school journalism
of
telling the facts and telling it like it
is has gone the way of the dodo that's
all about
pleasing your base telling things that
they want to hear
echo chambers what you've talked about
that's the reason that msnbc is just
talking about trump
let's talk about basically the one
character that everyone of our audience
dislikes okay there's a trump story
clearly it's a business model
we're going to get clicks let's go with
it fox you know
biden isn't gonna get the click so who
do they talk about aoc
kamala brian stelter cnn so they too
took the msnbc business model and said
let's talk about who our audience
dislikes i think the most shocking
differences the difference is
the the difference is based on what we
just saw to give
credit to give credit fox speaks about
the most
different topics variety
cnn is the second most different topics
msm is last i thought cnn was first
no fox fox has the most variety of
stories
cnn had no uniformity they were just it
was like 25 percent
but i had a bunch of others but what i
didn't do is i didn't do it the way i
did it with this the only thing that was
consistent here
was camelot but everything else was the
way i did it here is there trump was
four out of 12 and then they had a
couple that was two or three
so but these guys are variety biden
stelter california tucker
china it's variety i get it because
they're different topics but the
uniformity there
is that they're all topics that their
audience is not gonna
appreciate meaning they don't like aoc
they don't like kamala
they don't like brian stelter so they're
playing to their base in a certain time
so let me ask you a question to you so
do you think cnn should take a play
out of the msnbc playback well the fact
that their ratings are down 30
and they maybe want to consider doing
that yeah okay that's actually
what i'm most shocked about is that cnn
isn't doing that the fact that they're
not there yeah meaning they're maybe not
as
left as you someone's about to get fired
if that's right listen there's only so
long you can go without viewership until
somebody fires you
yeah well that's also so the the the
good and the bad
of biden is the people he we whether you
like buying or not
a part of the reason why he was elected
was because he's not going to be in the
news
and tweeting and i think many people
will disagree with you but that's
but there's going to be 80 million
people that probably do agree i don't
think so
what do you mean why do you think he was
elected so i don't think so i think
i think it's the the one of the best
quotes i heard like eight years ago
is people don't vote for somebody they
vote against someone
meaning they voted against trump they
didn't agree they didn't vote because
they wanted a guy to be calm they voted
because the media did a fantastic job
selling all the problems in america on
trump by the way
this is coming from a guy that right now
if you had to choose
curiosity i'm going to ask everybody
here this question see what you're going
to say
would you rather have a desantis win
2024 or a trump
win 2024. if desantis runs 2023 would
write plans would you consider voting
for him
yes i would you would consider voting
for him you're saying trump
yeah no no not rather than trump
desantis versus biden
based on what he's done over the last 18
months yes i would
you would consider voting for desantis
that's the point so so just the fact
that you're saying yes i would
ought to tell the republican party that
there's a camp like you that would
consider desantis
what is the likelihood of even if
trump's policies
in every mathematical calculation we run
benefits you your
family your future family your kids in
every possible way it benefits adam
would you vote for trump in 2024.
his policy highly likely no because
emotionally you can't stand the guy you
don't hate himself but you don't like it
emotionally it's just no it's all
emotional
it's time to move on from from him like
we're talking about it's not going to
remix a bad stuff
that's not what i ask you ask a very
simple question what i'm asking you is
you to me are more the american voter
than anybody else
you're the american voter okay if we win
you we win an election i agree because
you're the
you could win people like me with a
desantis that's what i'm saying you
can't win people like me with that's
wrong that's
there's no shots you're being taken i'm
talking to like a reasonable
conversation
so what i agree what i'm trying to say
to you is the the
the people have to decide who they can
convert that's on the middle
to flip i know a lot of republicans that
voted for obama because they wanted to
have a dream
first time to say what hey we got a uh
uh
first black uh president to tell my kids
anybody can become a president i think
that's a good story
i'm willing to vote for it once i don't
know about second time if he screws up
i'm not gonna vote the second time i
kind of like his dream story i kind of
like what he's doing
but there's no way in the world if
everything you wrote on a piece of paper
i want all these policies
and if trump was able to do every
policy you wanted and biden didn't want
to do it you still wouldn't vote for
trump
if you're actually looking at policies
black and white then yeah i would
consider
trump's behind the policies yeah well
policies
are are obviously very important but
let's not
let we can pretend all we want but it's
not like i agree with all his policies
so what i'm so what i'm saying is but
the point i'm trying to make to you is
there is the folks like you
in america there's people that are not
willing to vote for the guy just because
they don't like the guy even if the
policies are 80 million plus people i
agree
okay that's they voted against him
nobody voted for biden there's no way in
the world biden wins
anything else ever yeah that's how
polarizing trump is is that he's that
divisive of a character
that's how great of a job the media did
to hate this guy
that's how fantastic of a job the media
did today they get credit for it just
saw some of the great things he did
for 13. partially the media but you're
giving them partially the media you're
giving the media a lot of credit here
a lot of shooting himself partially to
me wouldn't partially
who convinced you of russia for three
years trump
no partially the media you're saying
trump has no
yeah but the media what i'm asking you
is who convinced you of russia trump did
who who even made us talk about russia
and trump who
mostly the media is it no no it's not
mostly
it's only the media well trump did some
stuff to make you
question no like the fact that he would
never bro if
ever if i criticize people if i had a
and like was cozying the legislature
so i've interviewed michael and and
michael francis right he's a mobster
yeah
let's just say i've interviewed sammy in
the past before and let's just say we've
had an exchange in text
okay hey uh we're on our way we'll see
you there shortly hey i just want to let
you know here's what's going on
imagine that being used 20 years from
now to say he's connected to the mob
we have to be care and i'm running for
governor and they say he's connected to
the mob
hey you know but the point is anything
and everything to use and then imagine
now i want you to actually think about
this
go to 2041.
it's 2041. i've got 28 kids i've got
five wives i've got 19 cats okay so it's
2041.
it's 2041. all right and we did i'm
gonna run for office
i'm gonna it's not gonna happen but i'm
gonna run for office i don't have any
desire to run for governor but i'm gonna
run for office let's just say
story comes back out do you want a
made man as a governor why is he so
close to the mob why is he down so many
why do they trust him do you trust the
man that's trusted by the mob
those campaigns by the way i as a
campaign guy i just gave them ideas it's
a five-year-old
they're people like [ __ ] no i don't want
someone like that now
some of the people who like mob movies
they may say kind of want that guy on
myself
what a freaking compliment to give on
the podcast you'll be like this
the moral the story is media controls
it all period media knows how to make
anybody look good my dad told me in
america patrick here's one thing you
need to know about america
america will turn into a hero in one day
and they're going to turn you into zero
the next day
and if they want to they'll lift you
back up but they do it you don't control
that
they're going to be able to do it this
is why you got to be able to control the
narrative so that's all i'm saying about
this year
the point is whether it's him or
desantis they got to start thinking from
that
make a quick point talk about this
scenario what if we put the energy and
the
resources behind an investigation into
any links to russia that biden has
or his son that they did with trump
could you imagine what they would find
out i mean if the roles were reversed
and there was actually maybe some stuff
to actually investigate and to find
could you imagine
of course that will never ever ever
happen already done that what do you
mean
you don't think they've never done it oh
my gosh no
there's a part of you like if there's
anything that upsets the audience like
for me i will say trump screwed up in
this
area you cannot tell me the level of
bias like if
if donald trump jr was caught using the
n-word in text
yeah big dog you know if if he was
how long would have the media share that
for the next six months how long
how long would you have heard that story
for how long
all over the news yeah what have you
heard about hunter briden have you seen
those texts i have not you know why you
haven't seen the text
because you probably watch a lot of cnn
and ms i watch only youtube
so so then you haven't seen that because
on the youtube
short clips of cnn and msnbc i watch fox
news i haven't seen anything on facebook
there is
of course that would cover it but fox
doesn't go like others do and say
millions of times of the same thing
about russia they cover it and they move
on to the next door
how many times did fox news cover
benghazi and then once hillary clinton
was out
you're defending someone that's
indefensible people died yeah
you're talking about lives how many
times did you talk about hillary's
emails in benghazi
because it was true listen if you're
going to do that if you're going to if
you're going to call people out there
ended up being true the email ended up
being true the emails of hillary clinton
that she trashed them and that was that
was true just so you know
the 33 000 emails that's an accurate
story that's not a
dossier the russia is a fake news okay
that is fake news
the story about hunter biden on his
laptop is true news that is not fake
those text messages are
real right that's not like a fake thing
that so
fake stories they market the hell out of
it true stories
they kind of stay away from it there's a
little bit of hypocrisy there by the way
again
i'm telling you guys if there's ever
been a time for a media platform to just
come out and tell both sides of the
stories where the audience can make a
decision for themselves yeah
it's now today's the time to do it at
the time it's yeah give both sides of
the story
the america is craving common sense
they're just looking for that by the way
did you guys see the story over the
weekend and i know this guy very well
personally his name is christopher sein
he was an anchor in alabama okay in
birmingham he was the 10 o'clock anchor
and he's from alabama he played football
at alabama
i knew him because he used to work at
abc in phoenix great guy unbelievable
family man
three kids he was the guy that broke the
story of loretta lynch on the tarmac at
sky harbor airport 45
in 2016. okay and that bill clinton got
out of his plane
in 112 degree heat walked over and spent
20 minutes in the plane with loretta
lynch
when they were investigating hillary and
the email server
okay he received tons of death threats
tons of credible death threats
because he wrote a book about it and
when he went on the publicity tour they
were coming together
threats
which makes no sense if anybody knows
him it makes no
sense it's almost physically impossible
to convince somebody that knows him
that he committed suicide the guy loved
life he loved his family more than you
can imagine he was yucking it up with
his co-workers on friday night
talking about what they were going to do
that weekend the next morning he's dead
so i don't know that's all i got but he
was a great guy
rest in peace great family pull around
the clintons if you say something
that's a lot of people that come in as
if the moment you say something about
you're like
my life's not worth it let me take my
own life it's either that
or it's something else that's the
speculation part
look you ever you ever had a friend in
school
or a colleague or something where every
time somebody got close to that person
either their life got worse or their
business got worse
after about a few years you have to sit
there and say dude does this guy really
want the best for me or not
there's something going on there like
for example let's just say
you and i start you've never hung out
with me before okay we start hanging out
together
next thing i know you're gaining 30
pounds
next thing i know your savings depleted
next thing i know you picked up a lot of
bad habits next thing i know you
got a couple dui's you're getting
arrested you're doing stupid things that
happen into your life
next thing i know you're creating a lot
of new enemies that you never had before
me and then same story here same story
there same story with like
45 people there's something going on
over there right there's something going
on over there but
i didn't even want to go to that store
you just kind of brought it up all i'm
saying is
msnbc 13 413 cnn 4412
fox 5'4 44 uh 5413 is kamala which is
what's
in the reason why fox is doing kamala
last week is because of the whole
border thing where he went and she
interviewed with who's the person at the
who was the person that interviewed
kamala last week uh it was uh
lester holt lester holt and lester who
is
and at the end he says how come you're
not going to the border and she says
what
we've been to the response is ridiculous
yeah we've been to the border and he
says no no how come you haven't been to
the board
uh because i don't because because
i don't want to bring it the attention
because it no she goes i also haven't
been to europe
but what are you going to say it was
just
that's the part of it words probably she
was covered five times i don't know look
all i'm saying is what do you think her
reason is that she hasn't gone to the
border
because if she does go to the border
everybody has to cover it and if
everybody covers it it shows how
ugly it is and makes the current
administration look like crap
and it gives a prior administration to
say here's what we did
look what the hell is going on today
under their regime look what's going on
in their regional politics
and she doesn't have the power she
doesn't have the chops to handle a
problem like that she knows she's
way in over her head on that issue she
has no clue what she's doing regarding
the border
yeah i mean it is what it is at this
point uh you know we'll see what's gonna
happen there let me go to the woke story
i saw the story that i thought it was a
very good story to share with everybody
this uh story was given to me by tom
ellsworth let's go to page five
tom sent me this story i read in the
middle of the night kai did i send it to
you i sent it to you i said read the
story here
it's a story uh advice to grads
b warriors not walksters scott galloway
who's a current professor i think at nyu
the guy is an absolute
instead of a guy and i don't know if i
want to read this whole thing
how long would it take me to read this
story one minute i want to read the
story i want to read this story so check
this out i'm a fast reader so we'll go
through it together
oh you're going to read the whole i'm
going to read this i'm going to read
this last week on my
on my way to e to jack's wife frida
awesome in soho a young woman in purple
gown
with all the versions of herself until
until nearly ran over me
ran me over it's that time of year
approximately 4 million young adults and
their loved ones will be forced to
listen to someone my age tell them how
to clean up the mess of our generations
leaving for them right
my bromide be warriors not wokesters be
mentally and physically
physically warriors lift heavy weights
and run long distances in the gym and in
your mind
many tasks you'll be asked to perform
early in your career will be tedious
don't do what you are asked to do
but what you're capable of doing think
of it as boot camp before
uh being sent to battle as there are
millions of other warriors fighting to
win the same
region of prosperity get strong really
strong you should be able to walk in a
room and believe you could overpower
outrun outlast every person that room by
the way i love that sentence right there
let me read it one more time
you should be able to walk into a room
and believe you could overpower
outrun or outlast every person in that
room what a great word
out last my first job was i want morgan
stanley dean witter great place to have
a first job at
i wasn't as well educated as the other
junior analyst my fault ucla is a
sink or swim place i decided to do
neither neither in smoke pot and uh uh
tread water anyway at morgan other every
other week i'd go to uh
work tuesday mornings and not leave
until wednesday night go to work tuesday
morning and not leave work until
wednesday night
nobody was at home waiting for me i had
no real hobbies and in your 20s
if you don't tell yourself otherwise you
can work 30 hours straight easily
30 hours straight this guy right
send a message to your colleagues that
you came to play many of you will have a
gag
reflex at my boomer capitalist mentality
or some [ __ ]
no it's america platform to deploy
skills and grit to add value and garner
resources every day america becomes more
like itself
and becomes a better country for people
who have resources
or influence and what a balance fine
many people who thoughtfully calibrate
the trade-off and fashion a good life
for themselves and their families
without being obsessed
with work and money assume you are not
that person if you are in your 20s
and reading this newsletter you don't
want balance you're after influence and
relevance
the world isn't yours for the taking but
for the trying
try hard really hard then it goes into
stoicism
talking about the power of stoicism
meaning control your emotions all that
other stuff
balances emit there are only trade-offs
having balance at my age is a function
of lacking
it at your age your call let me read
that one more time having
balance at my age he's a boomer right
now he's an older guy
having balance at my age is a function
of lacking
it at your age meaning grads 22 year
olds
your call personal life work the monk
warrior intelligence is the ability to
hold two contrary thoughts
concurrently this sounds easier than it
is our brains are wired for quick
assessment
were descended from millions of
generations of creatures who
whose ability to synthesize novel
stimuli with a lifetime's data and
formulate a faster than thought response
kept us from becoming another creatures
dinner
until recently when strangers
encountered each other only one left
alive but that feature is also a bug
when we react faster than thought we
don't react
thoughtfully we optimize for short-term
emotional satisfaction rather than
long-term prosperity let me say that one
more time
we optimize for short-term emotional
satisfaction
rather than long-term prosperity there's
a lot of discussion rethought
what it makes it means to be woke some
of it is well-founded
some of it is hyper um hyperbole
yes be awake to the privileges and
prejudices that surround you
and rigorously honest about the world
you're inheriting but the word has lost
its original meaning
beyond the media noise an insidious
pattern is emerging academic and
professional setting
the instance on filtering everything
through the lens of personal identity
and experience the prioritization of
victimhood
the belief that to be offended is to be
right structural racism is real and
he covers that so go a little bit lower
there's a part of it i really want to
cover here
reacting to every slight and demanding
satisfaction from every insult is what
system wants you to do
joining a twitter mob season on a
hapless middle manager or an
out of touch english professor may feel
like justice but it's just a cheap drip
of dopamine lost in an ocean of social
media profits
be a warrior before you resort to
violence make a thoughtful assessment
register the intention of the
go a little lower what he says
accomplishments there's a part of it
that i love what he said he says
in life he gives it to three different
things go lower goal or lower
goal there's three things he said he
says in at your age
it's about relationship it's about
fitness and it's about
uh uh relationship fitness what's the
other word you work
work relationship and fitness commit to
those three things at that age
work relationship and fitness yesterday
i'm talking to t contiko comes into the
gym
i'd already read this article he says
dad what's more important this kid is
nine years old
says daddy what's more important is it
important for me to work out my brain or
my muscles
what a great question to ask nine year
old kid i said daddy what do you think
he says i think it's brains
he says dylan spends too much time on
his muscles i think for me it's brains i
said really yeah
i said you know what's important in life
he said what i gave him my whole lead
respect and improve love courageous and
tolerance understanding
i said i read an article by this guy
scott galloway i think i'm going to
share it with you what's that
he said there's three things you got to
put your time into it's hard work
it's fitness and it's relationships
those are the three things you got to
put your value into
the info he shared in this article was
so powerful that it got me to transfer
to my kids because it was that
powerful of content to share what are
your thoughts on this article you know
he's so articulate so thoughtful
um it took a lot of guts for him to
write that and clearly these are his
beliefs but to stand up like that as a
professor at nyu it'd be interesting to
see what the reaction
from his colleagues is but you know how
can you argue against
what he said how can you take anything
all that
what he laid out in that newsletter how
could you make a rational
argument against any of it here's the
answer you cannot
okay and right now the country is
divided into two different types of
people it's
it's people like that follow the
doctrine of what he is talking about
here
and want to excel want to achieve want
to bust their ass
if things don't work out if you fail
along the way it happens you dust
yourself off and you keep going that's
what's called
america and then you have this other
loud minority
loud that wants everything handed to
them
they want to point out all the imbalance
and everything um
i think there's a tipping point at some
point in this country i'm praying that
there is
uh you have another voice of reason
that's out there bill maher and i've
seen scott galloway on
what works he's doing right and i've
seen galloway on his show
and he had a great point he was on bill
uh bill maher's show in march and
here's how he describes woke-ism he goes
what we have right now
is an industrial shaming culture making
a caricature of comments
and then using that to extract to an
ugly place so you can get virtue points
and the moment you're offended you feel
like you're right you know that you have
the right to uh
to be right about the issue so i hope
his voice gets stronger
gets louder um i just i just don't think
rational americans can take much more of
this we have a situation in our city
right now in manhattan beach
that's reaching a very very critical
tipping point having something to do
with what happened in the city
over a hundred years ago that nobody
that lives there now had anything to do
with it involving this
this place called bruce's beach and it
was once owned by a black family
and then they lost it and now they're
going to get it back etc but it's turned
into something really really
ugly so you know if you're a concerned
citizen
you're reaching out to the city council
and i'm just i'm emailing them saying
hey look
it's time for common sense to prevail
you know because there's no common sense
out there
anywhere there's just in politics in the
media or anywhere so
kudos to him he's a voice of reason um
and
like i said i just don't think you can
argue with it even though it's
goes against everything that his fellow
professors believe what are you thinking
yeah mad respect to scott galloway here
i think when he he talks about work
fitness and relationships
something that i always talk about is
you know mind body soul so like
obviously you know work your mind work
your body and you know be fit but work
your soul that's relationships and being
a good person and
focusing on what you're doing so respect
on that i don't think there's anyone who
would argue with
the power of mind body soul or in this
case uh work fitness relationships
something that that stuck out to me with
that is the millions of years
of quick uh reactions and quick
processing stimuli to say
oh [ __ ] that's a saber-tooth tiger i
gotta run or oh my god that's a dinosaur
i gotta go
and that's essentially the good and the
bad of what we have today
with all the twitter mob and the
keyboard warriors
and the feelings on your fingertips is
you could see something boom comment i
hate that guy
oh he's a piece of [ __ ] uh he should be
canceled like
the the quick nature of being able to
just basically
authorize your feelings to the outside
world
because of this you know we could say a
lot of good things about this but this
basically can get you in a lot of
trouble too
so the twitter mob and the cancel
culture mob
is a real thing these days and i totally
agree with scott the problem is
you know gen z uh who is basically who
he's talking to because he's
this is it a graduation speech where is
this exactly no you just wrote it
but this is advice to grad absolutely
we're graduating in college so
your daughter just graduated she's gen z
do you know the other word for the gen z
like i'm a millennial you're a gen x
you're a gen right
you know the other word for gen z is the
igen as in iphone generation
like there's an entire generation of
people
called the ijet meaning they're born
with an iphone in their hand
so as much as i wanna understand where
he's coming from you've got
millions and millions and millions of
young americans young people around the
world
that are born with this literally in
their hand okay
and it's hard to escape this it's hard
to say yeah yeah i totally i'll
i'll check my feelings and process it
and and give it 24 hours and then i'll
like you used to talk about you told a
story about if you were gonna fight with
your wife
and if before you had a phone and you
were leaving the office you'd have a
half hour to process it and cool off
now these days it's like [ __ ] you i'm on
my way home and not it's like
take a freaking second and relax that's
also the problem with having this
and everything at your fingertips is
that you can just respond to anything
immediately you see something online
comment dislike cancel and that's the
good and the bad of having the iphone
and being an igen and i
i think that's one of the reasons why he
and so many others are pushing the
concept of stoicism
stoicism to me is a very necessary thing
to be taught nowadays kai what
is there schools that teach socialism as
a course not just like in a philosophy
course like is there
a course you can take in school about uh
how to be a stoic or no is there
probably not in school right i think
there's so much benefit to it i read
meditations years ago i don't know how
many years ago it was really let me tell
you i've read it so many times
have you had a chance you haven't read
that yeah you told me to get it right so
meditations when i read i'm like man you
know a part of me watching my dad
it's a part of like he is a natural
stoic right there's a lot of benefits to
thinking that way because nowadays if
you
are not a stoic and you don't know how
to control your emotions
you will be driven insane constantly
worried about things you have zero
control over the ability to manage your
emotions on things you have no control
over
is such an invaluable skill set today it
is so valuable today for your career
for your relationships for being an
investor for being an entrepreneur for
being a businessman for being a human
being
for being a parent in every possible way
it's a lot of work but
i love the article by the way i just
sent the link in
the chat box if you're looking at it you
can go subscribe to his newsletter i
highly recommend you going out out there
and doing that
uh he's got a lot of great commentary
out there did you ever see this before
what's that this uh things you control
things things you can control
things that matter and then at the
tipping point in the very middle that's
where you should focus
meaning control what matters if you
can't control it
you can't control it if it doesn't
matter
then why are you focusing on stay
controlled so focus on things you can
control and that matter
if you can't control it and if it
doesn't matter why are you spending time
brilliant so uh shout out to marcus
aurelius
i love it awesome let's go to the
netanyahu story page 10 adam i want to
get your commentary on this
uh your thoughts obviously it happened
very quickly you told us this was kind
of
has been in the works for a while but
let's go through it bottom of page 10
netanyahu as prime minister after
israeli parliament votes to form a new
coalition government he's out
as prime minister business insider story
the israeli parliament on sunday voted
to form a new coalition government on
seating prime minister benjamin
netanyahu
who has led the country for the last 12
years naftali bennett a longtime
netanyahu ally turned adversary assumed
the role of prime minister and was sworn
in sunday bennett is the head of the
country's right wing
yamana party and as an ultra nationalist
multi-millionaire according to the ap
netanyahu sat quietly during the vote
after the vote he shook bennett's hand
and briefly sat in opposition's leader's
chair
before he walked out of the cham chamber
so that's how much we have
here in the story adam what's really
going on there
okay so what's going on here and i got a
lot of notes here and i'll try to break
this down into three
major parts so obviously israel and
everything that was happening in gaza
has been
all up in the news for the last couple
of months uh but everything that's been
going on with
bibi netanyahu has really a couple years
they've been trying to get him out of
office
and 12 years he's been in power that's a
long
time especially for a democracy so let
me start off with saying this i'm very
pro-israel the more that i've dug
deeper into the subject look where
israel is look who its neighbors are
to the north you've got lebanon and
syria stable no
to the right you've got jordan pretty
stable south egypt pretty unstable
you get iran you've got afghanistan
you've got saudi arabia
name one of those countries if you're an
american the map of israel while
the audience can name one of those
countries if you're an american
and you and you're pro-american that has
your back that has your best interest
out of any of those countries you can
name one israel
so they're the only democracy in the
middle east
they're in the literally the most
dangerous part of the world you've
come from iran you understand how deidre
is up there people don't understand that
the sunnis are fighting with the shiites
and then you get the kurds
and you got different sects and
different um types of people and the
fact that israel in the middle of all
that is a democracy
that should just tell you everything you
need to know about democracy are they
perfect no
do they have issues in the country just
like america yes
that moves on to this to the second
thing um
they have issues in this country just
like on america there's trump and then
on the left
you know you've got biden and you've got
obama and then you have aoc and on the
right you've got ted cruz
essentially the best way to understand
israeli politics is let's use american
politics to basically understand what's
going on there
netanyahu was trump okay he's been in
power for a long time
is it trump or reagan i don't i mean he
was
i mean i'm just using modern times he's
more of a trump type of
ultra nationalist um
you know sort of hardline because that
that's
for the person that doesn't know if you
say netanyahu is trump
they they go to one place so they seem
more of a
extreme like personality like a trumpet
he's a little he's a little more
stoic than a trump if you you know can
you say he's more like a reagan maybe
you know he's a modern day reagan okay
so there's something that's polarizing
like trump he's very polarizing
polarizing
fair enough okay yeah um so just
understand that
they put a coalition together and i'm
trying to use american terminology to
break down what's going
on in israel yeah for today's world i'm
saying let's just pretend for the sake
of conversation
netanyahu was a trump okay so this
coalition government they put together
imagine if bernie sanders aoc
ilhan omar on the left teamed up with
joe biden
obama and then on the right ted cruz
mitt romney sort of the rhinos and they
all came together to form a coalition
government with one purpose and one
purpose only
to get netanyahu aka trump out of there
and they did it by a 60 to 59 margin
by one vote very slim margin
but basically it just it it's this is
the most
diverse government in israeli history
that's how much
all these sides of the spectrum left
center and right
basically said it's time for netanyahu
to go okay so
the person that's actually the prime
minister right now
naftali bennett is actually further
right
than netanyahu so it'd be like a ted
cruz
or who's further right than trump that's
that's maybe yeah sure he is now the
prime minister he's gonna be the prime
minister for two years this is person
who is very ultra nationalist sort of
even right more right wing
than netanyahu now for the first time
ever
there's you know there's a large arab
contingency in israel and this is
actually the first time
that they're going to have a play in the
government that's a pretty big deal
so there's 10 like that we talked about
the tensions in gaza
that thing needs to be rectified so as
much as pro-israel as i am as much as i
am a lover of democracy as and how they
are a beacon of hope in the middle east
what what's happening in gaza is not
sustainable and what's happening with
the settlements is not sustainable
there needs to be a two-state solution
at some point
and if it takes having a coalition
government
who are maybe open to sharing ideas with
one another
rather than one hardliner in bibi
netanyahu i think that's something that
israelis are yearning for and we'll see
if they can make anything worse but it's
not going to be easy steve anas if you
guys are listening
stephen and us if you're listening to
this steve lewis just gave a hundred
bucks and anas is giving a bunch of 20s
today if you guys are listening if you
have strong opinions about
the what just took place in israel put a
comment here if i'll see you if you're
on uh
and text us at 310-340-132 we may just
call you guys up if we got both of you
three one zero three four zero one one
three two go ahead tom
you know you mentioned the coalitions
and i guess this would be my question
if you have a coalition government with
all these extreme personalities and
ideas and your one objective
is to get a guy out and you achieve that
how do you govern because now you're on
opposite ends of the spectrum and now
you have to run a country and you have
to face some very serious issues like
iran
and what's going on you know as far as
trying to prevent them from having a
nuclear bomb
which is what netanyahu passionately did
by the way didn't netanyahu say he'd be
reinstated by august
i think i'm just joking that's trump's
yeah that's trump he did say
to quote arnold schwarzenegger i'll be
back yeah he did he gave an entire
speech in hebrew and he said three words
in english
i'll be back so netanyahu is not going
anywhere
this is why i'm kind of given the trump
analogy i'm not saying he's as
polarizing or maybe he is as polarizing
as trump but netanyahu is a character
who has been
really powerful he seemed extremely
diplomatic
agreed to me on the world stage on the
world stage
in israel he can be very uh divisive he
went scorched earth
on his exit press conference the other
day he won scorched earth and he
attacked biden
in that he went right after biden uh
regarding iran
so i'm just curious how this new
government is that's a good move i think
it's a good move yeah guys it shows
strength that's for sure
now not only shows strength he's saying
like you guys better keep an eye out on
what's going on with iran if the
negotiations continues with iran because
if u.s and iran get closer who who what
place is a more dangerous place to be
israel well because they would probably
use their damn nuke you know i mean
that's their whole
idea for having it so it'll be
interesting to see
what kind of um influence he has going
forward because you know when you're in
power for 12 years it's hard to give it
up
and how the new coalition government is
going to handle iran
let's talk about uh our friend scott
galloway to bring that back
one of his major uh three categories
that he said you should focus on is
relationships so
speaking of relationships netanyahu had
a pretty damn good relationship with
trump
to the fact when uh biden won election
uh you know how long it took him to call
bibi netanyahu
three weeks three weeks to call one of
your greatest allies
to call him he's probably got a rotary
phone doesn't know how to use a cell
phone maybe that's what it is
you know how long it took him to call
this naftali bennett one day
so uh the the the democratic party
here's
here's a message to all my democratic uh
party friends here in america
the democratic party is slowly but
surely becoming the anti-israel party
and that's something that's very
concerning as someone who has voted
democrat
and is pro-israel it it's it's becoming
more and more
likely that jewish people stephen i'm
going to call on us hang tight
are going to start hearing some of the
rhetoric that's coming out of the left
wing of the democratic party and saying
i can't stand for that i'm going to
start looking towards the right because
all my
orthodox jewish friends are any
conservative jewish friends they're
republicans
and 75 percent of of jews are more
liberal so if that tips
that could be an issue it could be an
issue and you're seeing a lot of folks
on the left kind of talk about what the
hell is going on over there an area that
we all agree on
stephen asked can you guys hear me yeah
i hear you well uh
uh our friends are back today steve can
you hear me as well i heard an ass can
you hear me as well
steve do we have you on i think we just
lost steve hank type for me one second
let me call steve
uh yeah even what's his name you know
who's your call has been for
come on steve pay the bill steve texas
does he text us but uh uh
let me see here give me one second
you know you never doubted for a second
where trump stood on israel ever
your call has been forward
okay guys if you're listening just call
that number back both of you guys will
get you you never you never doubted
where he stood
on israel i mean he was probably the
most friendly president for
israel ever i mean ever look when you
got
the did russell brandt love trump
no did bill maher love trump no no
at all did did you know scott galloway
did these
people sit there and say oh trump's the
greatest thing since sly spread no
no they're all in agreement on what's
going on right now with the democratic
party on positions they're taking like
what the hell are you doing like it's
almost like dude
what are you doing you're offending the
family you know what i mean like hey
you're not making a family look that i
don't stand for that
i don't i'm willing to defend my side to
a point but not for this
yeah i've been a die-hard laker fan for
my entire life since the day i came to
the states
i came november 28 1990. you know what
happened couple months after that
it's the bulls lakers final it's the
bulls lakers final
it's the georgia going up over sam
perkins right i
watched that on black and white tv when
that took place and i'm a die-hard laker
fan
i was devastated when the lakers lost
i've just been in the states for a few
months when i saw that game i'm like
dude this is this sucks
my team just lost to this guy named
michael apparently everybody calls him
the greatest
and that was his first championship i
watched michael win every single
championship back to back to back
rockets rockets back to back to back and
then everybody else came right after
jordan when he left
i'm a laker fan but even as a laker fan
it's the first time the last two years i
have not rooted for them
because i don't like how the game is
being
manipulated into fans we have to agree
on one side just to
support the nba and how much it's in my
face today
i can't just enjoy a game anymore as a
fan
i've stepped away from the team for the
current time being i may come back but
i'm not rooting for the lakers but when
they lost i said good for the sons go
win a championship do whatever you got
to be doing right
by the way who you choosing to win the
whole thing between the teams that are
left well i got milwaukee
winning that series because of the
injuries you got milwaukee winning that
series
winning that series okay so i'm just
breaking it down round by round
uh i love atlanta they're a fun team to
watch but i think if milwaukee beats the
nets they're coming out of the east
i don't think the clippers are going to
beat utah i think maybe there's an issue
with kawhi's knee yeah
and utah's not going to lose at home so
i'm going with the suns
over utah and the western finals and
beating the bucks
in the uh nba finals give me the suns
i'm going to take
a shocker alert i'm going to take
brooklyn even though the kyrie's hurt
and that hardin is uh
hasn't been back yet i know you said
that they had a zero percent chance tom
uh but as long as one one of those two
guys are healthy
kevin durant looks ridiculous right now
so i'm talking i'm hoping milwaukee wins
i'm hoping milwaukee wins is who i'm
hoping for
uh uh is what i want to see back to your
analogy with why you're you know you've
been a lifelong lakers fan and now for
the last few years you're not exactly
rooting for the lakers i think sure
you're going through that right now i
think i think both sides
i think this is the power of being an
independent free thinker that if you're
just only saying i'm on this side
i'm on the i'm a democrat and i agree
with everything or i'm a republican
but and i agree with everything it's
very dangerous tell me which part of
policies on the right has changed
policies not positions not
not personality policies
you're saying what since trump has been
in office policies
policies for example let me explain to
what i mean by this yeah did the right
under trump all of a sudden go for
pro-life to pro-choice did the right all
of a sudden under trump go from
low taxes to high taxes did the right
under trump all of a sudden go from
you know protecting a country with
security to now no let's not do military
that the right under trump all of a
sudden go away from freedom of speech to
now you're being
controlled that so what policies change
what policy change on the
under obama what policies i shouldn't
say obama i'm saying under bite no i'm
saying
what policy i don't think either side
has changed policies
the problem that uh protecting the
protection of israel has always been
unanimous okay there used to be a time
there used to be a time i sent that
video to you
where we talked about it right where a
lot of the rich country clubs back in
the days
were ran by republicans and they did not
allow jews
right here at the what do you call it
right here right across the street
club what is the community called royal
palm is
a royal pump they did not allow jews to
live in that community but we're talking
50 60 years ago right because it was
like protecting 50's well it's the
recipients
that used to say no blacks no jews no
dogs that's basically what was going on
so that was then that's how that's how
pathetic it was then right yeah
and so they were welcomed by the
democratic party so the jews said i'm
part of the democratic party because
they welcome me they've had them
for 70 years they've had that vote the
democrats had the black vote for how
many years since 60
1960. that's 60 years they've had that
vote right
gradually if they're flip-flopping with
their position of no longer supporting
the jewish community in israel they
could easily lose that vote today
easily lose that that's what i'm saying
what i'm saying the right
didn't change their policies the right
just
hated trump because trump called that
mccain trump called that bush trump
called that bush senior
trump called out a bunch of people who
are veterans on the right saying
i don't care if you're a prisoner of war
i want to make sure you don't get caught
like some of the comments
that's how he lost a lot of people not
policies well
some policies he did change the
tradition such as like free trade
he began trade wars i think the
republicans had a trade war there was
abuse and for many years everybody
wanted to go up against china but nobody
had the audience
give trump credit for that but that's
not policies
being a fiscal conservative not taking
on more debt trump brought on a lot of
debt
there's no i mean i think that's the
number that's been i think that's been a
uh
mutual thing since bush obama the last
20 years oh there's no denying that the
democrats don't take on debt but it's
the fact that republicans are supposed
to be more fiscally conservative
under trump i don't trillions of debts i
don't disagree with that but i think
that the big government thing happened
after bush
right after bush everybody wanted a
bigger government that's been happening
for a long time george w bush
oh yeah well after 9 11 and the tsa and
everything yeah big brother
looking at everything bigger and bigger
we've heard more anti-israel talk in
this country in the last three months
than we have in the last 30 years
and yeah and a lot of it is because it's
bds and it's happening on
boycott divest and um
whatever sanction against israel a lot
of the college campuses a lot of
let's go back to the woke crowd
something that people need to understand
enough we're gonna are friends on
like the most ironic part of i think the
the woke
liberal left anti-israel bds
is there was a um there was an image
of uh of a gay flag that was essentially
um gays for gaza essentially
and someone pointed out do you
understand that if you
actually that makes no sense had the gay
flag
in gaza they would full-on kill you but
if you had that in tel aviv israel they
would just hey good keep good luck like
that's that's the
the biggest joke is the fact that you
have the liberal woke left defending
these authoritarian hamas driven
terrorist organizations
and that don't understand how right-wing
they are
let me put into this it's a joke i've
talked about this maybe privately you
and i talked about it there was a guy
back in the days it was like the
the the the jimmy kimmel the jimmy
fallon the
johnny carson of iran his name was fedor
saudi
good looking guy very good can you pull
him up there's no way
to be able to spell it would you spell
that please
do that h f-a-r-o-k-h
z a d e h no no the fact that you're
even spelling it out
correctly f a r o k h
z a no no put it together it's one name
z-a it's like a john it's an easy name
z-a-d-e
it's like john h e h d-e-h
iran put iran okay now go there put
images
put images images images buddy
okay uh go go back uh
sometimes to the left right there to the
left it says
they're right there
right there just go right there thank
god that guy right there
okay so he was right there look at this
bart reynolds iranian man let me tell
you
good looking guy great voice great
performer look at that picture right
there of him look at that
that's a that's a commercial looking guy
yeah well anyways there is a
speculation that he was gay in iran and
later well based on that outfit i'm
gonna go
the the speculation was correct then if
that's the case half of men in america
who are metroid
you may yeah dress like that on the
podcast but you dress like that every
day when you're black and white
black and white does he not dress like
that every day he comes to work you guys
should see how adam dressed
as like a bull fighter i i would like to
be now uh called
salve that's my new name do not butcher
how you better spell that [ __ ] right
there anyway so he tells us about faulk
he was gay
you know the rumor had it that he liked
men yeah and anyways
eventually he's at a hotel in europe
they go find him
they chop them up it was they the
iranians the
hezbollah ayatollah's camp they find
them they chop them up
and they take his privates they put it
cut him up they put it in his mouth
to prove a point take a picture send it
out that's to say here's what we do to
folks like you
for everybody else we dare you to come
out the closet yeah do this behavior
again see what happens
folks in america think that's a joke
dude in iran would be driving
and if a girl has her hair being shown
back in the days i'm talking the air
when i lived there
back in the days if you had your hair
been shown they would take you they
would take you and whip your back
77 times you would hear that number
constantly so if you if you see
many times when you go to the beach and
you see a man or a woman in the back
that's got
her their back looks so like what is
wrong with this person's back
it's not what's wrong with their back
they got arrested they got whipped they
got lashes and iran
this was normal in iran it wasn't like
the news cnn eight o'clock tonight
you know john jones got slashed 77 times
and no it's not like that
just all right cool sounds good all the
best next time don't screw up yeah it's
a different kind of
culture so many people in america who
are saying gays for gaza
i challenge you to have the courage to
go do that
in actually gaza and see what happens or
do that in saudi arabia or do that
in iran or do that in syria or do that
in lebanon or do that in oman or do that
in yemen
good luck you can do it in tel aviv it's
rude and television anywhere in israel
that's right was was the guy that they
killed
was he on the air at the time was he
still a relevant personality and he's
always until the day he's talking about
that that's unbelievable
yeah so there's always these rumors
about what happened that's the one story
about there so
anyways let's go into inflation let's
talk about inflation page nine middle of
the page nine
inflation expectation for the next
year's search to record high fox
business story okay
inflation for the next decline for
seventh straight month in may to record
high according to a new survey from the
federal reserve bank of new york median
one year ahead of inflation expectation
last month rose
point six percentage points to four
percent the highest since the new york
fed survey of consumer expectations
began
inflation expectation over the short
term have in recent months been
increasing at a faster pace than a
medium term
the point four percent point difference
between the two is the
biggest spread on record respondents
also expect prices
for all commodities to increase over the
next year the median year ahead expect
expected change in food prices increased
2.2 percent
points to record height of eight percent
while the other year ahead expect change
the prices gas was point six percent
points to nine point eight percent my
prediction i've been saying that kai we
got to make a note for me to do that
video on gas prices
i predict gas prices in the next 12 to
24 months to it five to ten dollars
i was at it out of town a couple weeks
ago and i saw the gas prices
in california being at the uh uh what do
you call it uh no no no
premium was 489 is what it was regular
was 440.
today yesterday i was running out of gas
on my way to tsa building here in
what do you call it in florida by the
port barely found a gas station thank
god i did
270 260 what i'm paying for pathetic how
cheap the gas is over here compared to
but floridians are saying the gas prices
have come up i'm like this is nothing
compared to what it is inflation is
coming let me add that
with the other story together let me add
that with the other story together and
then i'm going to come to you guys for
your feedback
global tax rate could drive businesses
away from us
watchdog warns also business fox
business story
president biden leaders of g7 group
nations endorsed a global minimum
corporate tax rate of at least 15
percent of policy that could ultimately
drive business investments
away from the u.s that's according to
taxpayer protection alliance a nonprofit
advocacy group based in dc
which argues that a higher global
minimum rate would ultimately be passed
on to workers and consumers through
reduced compensation
and higher prices there's some evidence
to suggest that corporate taxes
are ultimately borne by workers and
consumers a recent analysis conducted by
the tax foundation suggested that up to
of the tax burden falls into labor as
the tax reduces
as the tax reduces investment
productivity and wages the dollar amount
of costs and labor may exceed the
revenue raised by the tax
by wide margin the tax foundation said
but the biden administration has argued
a minimum tax rate
will build a more equitable tax system
that will help deliver a foreign policy
for the middle class and it will help
support working families everywhere
thoughts on inflation and the tax rate
increasing globally i i can just speak
from one perspective
inflation is in the news every single
day isn't inflation a horrible thing
that we should be afraid of
terrible things okay for middle american
low income terrible things yeah and they
keep talking about it like um there's a
cold front coming and temperatures might
be like
three percent colder during march
through april uh they're making it seem
like it's a
like just a little small little
ticky-tack little inconvenience
i mean if this hits like every jamie
dimon's talking about how
jb morgan is throwing away as much cash
as they possibly can because
inflation is coming in a huge way i'm
scared as hell about it
you know i really am i mean how i know
what gas prices are because i pay them
in california you can see
other things inching up and you combine
that with the global shipping issues
that we have
and all the other things that are that
are in this pot and they're brewing
and it's going to be a very very
challenging time
coming for us very shortly so
we talked about two topics right there
the the inflation and multitasking
yes i mean the one thing that comes to
mind here is what i just kind of
showed you over here with my little uh
venn diagram
there's things that you can control and
there's things that matter and
where they coalesce in the middle is
where you should focus you're not gonna
stop inflation
bob sue joe mary it's gonna happen it is
what it is the only thing you control is
what's going on
in the four walls under your house so if
inflation is four percent in this coming
year
or if it's transitory and it will be
closer to two percent
historically inflation is what two to
three percent annually
anyway over time so inflation is going
to happen
there's nothing you can do to control it
and unless you're some
corporate tax avenger who actually has a
stance of what can happen at the
corporate tax rate
uh there's nothing you could do about it
so there's nothing you can do about
inflation
there's nothing you can do about the
global corporate tax rate the one thing
you can do
is focus on your own personal finance
and what i always say
save that money and then if you're
worried about inflation and you're
worried about
um your dollar not being as powerful as
it is now
then start investing in assets that um
provide a better rate of return or start
investing in assets that
always talks about keyboard let me ask
you this
how's the middle class going to invest
in any of that with inflation going up
they're looking to afford milk in gas
you're right insurance
you're right you're right by the way
you're absolutely right so here's here's
the issue
did you see the story about blackrock by
the way luis rodriguez from
ecuador if you can text zero one us at
two
i put the number down there louise text
us ecuador three one zero three four
zero one one three two i want to give
you a minute to share with us
how inflation affected ecuador so did
you see the story about blackrock going
and buying
homes from people and paying 25
about market rate did you see that
number of that story there i didn't see
that
it's not in here it's not in here it's a
story so they're going around and
they're buying
real estate portfolios and they're
saying listen half a million dollar home
will pay 600 grand 400 dollar home will
pay five hundred thousand
they're overpaying for homes so a lot of
oh my gosh sure people are buying at the
peak of the market they're just buying
right now i've said this myself right
that's market crash but when you start
printing money the way we printed money
the last 12 18 months in the fed
keeps the rates as low as they have do
you know how cheap money is right now
i don't even understand if people
realize how cheap money is right now
it's the cheapest it's ever been you
want to go get millions of dollars today
it's so cheap
you know the whole thing where uh uh
they talk about
they talk about the fact that it's not
fair that bezos
buffett all these guys barely paid any
taxes i don't know if we have one of
those stories
is that one of the stories i'll just go
to that's on page four at the top
25 richest americans paid no federal
taxes report the street
tesla's elon musk former new york mayors
michael bloomberg amazon's jeff bezos
the activist investor carl icahn
have all managed to pay zero income
taxes in at least one year in the past
15 years propublica reported billion
investor george soros managed to pay no
income taxes
three years in a in one year bezos paid
no income taxes 2011.
he even climbed and received they even
claimed and received a 4 000
tax credit for his children according to
the report from 2006 to 2018
bezos saw his wealth increase 127
billion dollars over the period he
reported six and a half billion dollars
in income
on which he paid 1.4 billion dollars in
federal taxes when compared with his uh
with his overall gains that amounts to
1.1 percent true tax rate
on the rise on his fortune uh top
topping the propublica's list is
uh berkshire hathaway's warren buffett
the oracle of omaha reportedly
had income of 125 million from 2014 to
paid 23.7 in taxes a true tax rate of
0.1 percent the way they're doing the
math right okay
so this concept becomes and by the way
somebody
leaked their taxes i don't know somebody
somebody from the irs which is a federal
offense by the way
anonymous oh anonymous and then you see
the the the press secretary's like oh we
are gonna get to the bottom of this no
you're not
this is irs giving you the story right
before you're pitching the idea of
raising taxes is a good thing
and look at all these rich people let's
turn them into bad people so then
so let's do this here's here's the other
way of thinking about it
all these incentives first of all
money's free it's easy today to get
meaning for the rich it's very free
interest rates are low
it's so easy to go get 50 100 200
million dollars today
if you have money there's this thing
when you have money they don't lend you
in my
15 year 20 years ago nobody gave me a
loan out of bank i couldn't get a loan
at a bank if i tried
hell if i wanted to rent a car from
hertz they wouldn't give it to me
because like we're worried because your
credit sucks so bad right
today everybody's just like hey you want
another 10 million you want another 40
million in 1.35 million you want another
20 million
here you go it's just money being given
away right because it's cheap
how do we get here rates stay low like
this
it's going to keep happening the
separation on the wealth is going to be
taking place now on the flip side when
you hear these stories about how bad the
rich people are
okay let's look at our compensation plan
that we have with taxes
let's look at the compensation plan that
we have in taxes and let's
let's get rid of all the incentives of
people to become entrepreneurs
what does america look like without elon
musk let's take them out there is no
elon musk
or a elon musk top of a person in the
last 20 years okay
which is not like somebody to say well
if there's not an elamas there will be
another illamas no no
say there is no elon musk type of a
person in the last 20 years
say there's no jeff bezos type of a
person last 20 years
say there's no warren buffett type of a
person last 50 years
say there's no car like the jobs the
whole point i'm trying to make to all
these guys
what does america look like is it a
better place no is it
is america a better place without bezos
musk buffett all of these in my opinion
no it's not a better place without them
no so so what what causes these guys to
be willing to go work to work their
tails off put so much
risk anxiety fear worry at night sitting
there oh my gosh i'm working like elon
musk for 20 years i never took a day of
vacation
buff gates for 20 years i never took a
day of vacation
how many people are willing to do that
there's a bunch of people that are
asking about a four-day work week these
guys work 20 years straight
the incentive is if i go 20 years
without working kind of like what scott
galloway said in his article yeah
he said i used to go on tuesday morning
and not come back to a wednesday night
you can work 30 hours straight
the incentive is how many people are
willing to do that at his age
not many anymore so if they do they
deserve the kind of wealth that they're
getting
if you try to punish them what happens
next is what
the next 20 years you will not have an
elon musk
the next 20 years you will not have a
basis being inspired by that
that's the part that people forget go to
some of the biggest socialistic
countries in the world
and tell me what incredible products
were produced there go
go to the greatest biggest socialist
countries and you tell me
what technology you use today that that
came out of a socialistic technology
what what technology well i don't know
what the hell they're doing in china but
they're doing something there but in
china
it's a different story in china china's
taking all the trade secrets from
america and they're trying to control to
make china more powerful
it's not innovation that's theft is what
it's called
but they set it up in a way on contract
where american people who got the money
they said it's not a big deal let's give
it to them so it's not called theft they
did it legally but it is theft
it's a thing of that theft of ipa theft
of ideas without letting you compete in
their country so
they're not even denying it we'll take
facebook from you we'll take all this
stuff from you but you can't have that
in our country but we can have it in
your country brilliant idea that they
have anyways
well this whole stuff with taxes and
influence let me ask you a question can
can there be two sides of this coin
meaning
i don't think it's right that you vilify
successful people like i don't think
that
uh anti-capitalist vilification of the
warren buffets of the world
and the bezos of the world and the most
of the world and all these guys who have
made a major influence steve jobs as you
mentioned
the vilification of these types of
entrepreneurs to me is is ridiculous it
is absurd
but at the same time can you also say
yeah
maybe they should pay their fair share
like warren buffett has said
i'm willing to pay more taxes meaning
can you
congratulate them why not but then all
i'm saying is do it do it dude you don't
let's not raise taxes but do it
give a billion dollars additional to
taxes go ahead just like charity go
ahead
a lot of them have signed up for the
billionaire pledge what i'm saying is if
you're
so noble of a human being where you say
i'm willing to pay more taxes why don't
you go ahead
you can a lot of them if i may answer
this a lot of them say i don't trust the
government to do it no [ __ ] you don't
neither do we either give it to neither
do we
don't give that line when you're worth
100 billion dollars just to look good in
the story while you kill the next buffet
that's coming up
buffett is the one who said that no [ __ ]
and i'm calling him out yeah
don't say that after you made your 100
billion dollars and you screwed up for
the next
17-year buffet that wants to come up
what the hell are you doing did you
forget when you were 17
you so you want to make it harder for
the next so you want to make the barrier
to entry
for the next buffet to come up you want
to make it harder for him that's what
you want to do so that's your policy
right there
yeah well i got my money already forget
about i'm about i'm 90 years old right
now
yeah i'm this old wise guy now and don't
worry young guys you don't need to be as
wealthy as me
it's not as good who are you to make
that decision for me now that you have
the money it's easy for you to say it no
yeah let the young 14 year old buffet be
inspired to be more than you so you're
saying that buffett's speaking out of
both sides of his mouth you're not
thinking about the
future generations look i asked the guy
one time i said
why why do some of these billionaires
who become so wealthy
why do they all of a sudden start
sympathizing and like oh my gosh all
this other stuff he says because they
feel bad they feel bad because of what
what do they feel bad about what the
only thing you ought to feel bad about
us
you know the documentary about vince
lombardi where they said at the end of
the days
lombardi wasn't a happiest guy when he
died there'd be parties he'd have drinks
and he'd step away and he would go cry
in his room by himself
and his wife would go to him and says
hey baby what's going on says i don't
know i don't know he wouldn't
he'd go and cry hardcore right and they
said this just doesn't make sense why is
lombardi doing this
so when i interviewed the coach of the
chicago bears mike ditka
and i'm sitting at his barn in uh
he mailed it in let me tell you why it's
the most boring his wife was sitting
right there when we did the interview
and i asked him about everything
kaepernick all this other stuff he says
you know what maybe i was wrong
fine maybe i was too hard maybe i was
too this i'm like dude that's not what i
want to hear
that's not what i want to hear because
what happens is
when you when you get older the energy
to argue certain arguments for you
it's just like i just don't care anymore
to do it right
so lombardi what is that background
noise by the way
who is it is it our guys can we just
tell them gerard ii
okay when you become older okay
and you get to a point where like
lombardi's going around he says finally
what would hurt lombardi was the fact
that he felt at the tail end of his
career was too tough on his players
he felt like he was too tough on his
players now when they interview the
players
can somebody step over there and just
have that conversation with gerard the
guy's so loud the whole country can hear
him right now
all right so he was so tough on his
players so they interviewed the players
and they said how do you feel about it
he says i disagree
because i wanted somebody like that in
my life
i wanted somebody that challenged me to
we did he said i never had anybody that
had such high expectations of me he says
don't get me wrong he was very tough
but i liked the way he was there was a
story about wonder wonder who was this
quarterback that played for him
uh bart starr bart star he says bart
star one day
lombardi's berating him in front of his
players
you can't even throw [ __ ] what the hell
is going on with you
he just trashed him in front of his
players bart says
coach can i talk to you yeah he comes in
he says hey coach
why can't you if you want me to lead my
players
please don't undermine me in front of my
players can you do to me privately
he says he never did it ever again bar
star said that he says because i just
want to have the conversation with him
right
as people age and he gets i don't know
what it is to be 90 years old
and to be closer to heaven or to be
closer to
you know whatever age of 20 30 to relate
to that
as you get older you become disconnected
with the younger ah you forget who you
were at 15. sure
bro there's this book on lincoln called
lincoln on leadership
and one of the things he talks about is
circulate amongst your troops
the moment you no longer relate
to the minimum wage person and you
forget who you were you know that whole
song by
jennifer lopez which is what don't be
fooled by the rocks that i got i'm still
i'm still jenny from the block i used to
have a little now i have a lot no matter
where i go
remember by the way to me the only
reason that's my favorite jlo song is
because the words
i don't listen to but that but the word
i'm still um
the point is the point is buffett forgot
when he was just warren from the block
he forgot yeah he did he said a rough
don't be fooled by the stocks that i got
yeah and i think part of it is that
negative guy underneath him charlie you
know his
younger yeah you know he's about as
bitter as you can possibly get
you know in regards to the the the tax
that the rich are paying
no one's accusing them of breaking any
laws and if if you
have that type of wealth you have people
that are smart enough to stay one step
ahead of the tax code and the irs and to
figure it all out
which makes me think they'll just figure
out the next thing too right
they always do yeah and by the way adam
said there's nothing we can do about it
actually
we can when it comes to inflation we can
vote out the people that are in power
when inflation hits and that usually
does happen
dude by the way this guy in motown music
factory i don't know who it is because
there's not a name behind
i just gave 10 bucks and he said america
will look worse than detroit
without people like elon musk just ask
jack ma
i agree and i'm going to give you ten
times what you gave us which is a
hundred dollars
let's make a note kai the motown music
factory send us a text to three one zero
three four zero one one three two we're
about to send you a hundred dollars
because i agree with you as well we have
to recognize these people and build them
up
we're trashing innovators right now
we're destroying innovators right now
everything is about you know the the
people today there is a business model
on youtube for just trashing
others constantly we enjoy that people
are enjoying
seeing it right it is a model that
happens i posted a picture of the house
i bought right because
barons did a story on it and then uh a
real
real deal did a story on a bunch of
people did a story on it and so finally
uh my guy says what do you want to do i
said tom why don't we write them put the
pictures up so tom wrote the story on uh
uh
vpos.com hey you know uh uh
what do you call it uh bought this house
and for north fort lauderdale
record-breaking whatever 20.4 million
auto house i bought right last week and
i got the keys and i flew
out right the moment i got the keys but
i slept in it two times this day three
times this weekend
taking a shower the other day and thank
god it's covered here on the bottom but
the top is not perfect i'm taking a
shower i'm looking around at the top is
open so when it rains you see the rain
and i'm looking like oh my gosh from a
freaking apartment complex in granada
hills where drive-bys were taking place
too
who the hell would believe this story if
i told you in high school one day pat
hey
if somebody said pat one day at 42 years
old they're going to limit this kind of
house
i said what the hell are you on right
now the drugs are using that's the
american dream
but you know what there was a lot of
messages that came but there was a lot
of messages that came with send me money
there's a lot of messages that came that
you know you could have given that how
money to this there was a lot
everybody has their own dream to some
people the dream is
a different dream to some people it's
relationship to some people it's a house
to some people is
something big they want some people is
their legacy of their you know they want
to do something with big with it
thank god for the ambitious people who
have big dreams
and they try to do it the right way
they're going to break rules there's no
way in the world you're going to be big
without breaking the rules
but they don't break the laws but you
can break the rules you have to break
the rules sometimes to do something big
with it
thank god for them sometimes we just
have to sit there and be grateful
the fact that we had a chance to witness
a michael play when people tell me
i was looking at art in wynwood i was in
woodward two days ago
and i go to this one art store the guy
sees me he's like
oh [ __ ] i'm like what the hell i'm with
the
uh senna and anyways we're senna mario i
think we're out there
and uh carol so we go he goes to the
back hey hey come here
say hey i'm al this is cal and this is
val
cool good to meet you guys this is sad
we watch all your interviews
oh you watch the business interviews no
just the mob interviews
okay so you're the mob audience right so
we're sitting there we're talking and
uh uh what was i what story was i
telling right now is it talking about
the fact that um
uh your house your arts haters no it's
the art the haters
oh man huh different dreams what was it
man i was about to tell a good story
with what happened
art yeah i forgot what the story was but
it had to do with that place because i
was looking at an art with this guy
anyway so come on
in wynwood i don't know where i was
going with this but uh
the house start what was it where was i
going with this i'll get with it here in
a minute okay but get mentally back into
that shower
yeah get back there you're feeling good
you were talking about everybody has a
different
type of goal and it might be a house for
somebody
yeah i i just think we forget that man i
think we forget the little kid that
has a dream that wants to do something
big and
rather than go forget about the 50 year
old elon musk i don't know how old elon
musk is i'm assuming he's in his mid-40s
too late yeah
mid-50s he's 49 on the fantastic right
now dude
go look at elon musk not as 49.
take a look at elon musk as a 12 year
old kid who kept
reading those books and imaginations and
people call them weird
who had an imaginary friend you know who
had
all those weird things that he did and
he had a dream dude
don't look at him as that 50 year old
guy look at him as the
by the way even biden you know what i
look at with biden i don't look at biden
as
who he is today i look at bite i'm like
this guy probably when he was coming up
he was like he had a dream one day he's
going to be a
a president right the guy's got the
ultimate like the lowest underdog like
you know who he is he's like when the
florida marlins won the world series
that's joe biden if you think about that
yeah it's like you know
jay buener you know pudge rodriguez all
those guys the great pitchers randy was
there i think i think randy was there i
don't know who their picture was they
had a good picture there
but the point is we forget those stories
as much as you may disagree with
someone's
ideas trump at one point had the
pressure of the father
boarding you know they're sending him
away go at this place figure out your
life the resentment if you love me so
much why do you send me to a boarding
gods
guy becomes a billionaire becomes a
presidential i mean
dude you got to plot some of these guys
so the world wouldn't be the same
without these people
we demonize them way too much yeah and
the media's grabbing hold of this social
warfare this class warfare and they're
running with it and it's
it's dangerous you know it's making
these people seem like they're evil or
that they should feel guilty about
making all this money
how about elon musk when he almost lost
tesla i mean he was working 20 to 22
hours a day trying to save it
so there's that too so yeah that's true
by the way this doesn't mean
you know everything with taxes to me is
a sales company's compensation structure
what incentives do you want create a
sales structure
compensation structure based on that
hopefully they'll do something about it
all i know is right now they're trying
to
drive it in a way to demonize rich
people and i don't think it's going to
work
and work out for them long term uh what
story do you guys want to go to
what did what story did you get any art
i did
i did i'm looking at a couple banksies i
uh purchased a mr brainwash yesterday
nice it's a sick mr brainwash i don't
know if you're familiar with mr raymond
like they're telling people that's
actually the transition for that one
yeah
the brainwashed stuff like a picture of
an older it's an iconic
presence that he makes all uh i love his
work dude i walked in and
i walked in i said i want that right
there and i told mario don't tell the
guy i want it but i want that so
we came back he had a massive price tag
on it i'm like let me count so let me
think about i don't know if i'm unwanted
or not and then we called
yesterday i wired him the money and it's
coming in this weekend to be here friday
i am in love with this piece it's got
two my favorite characters
one is chaplin and one is einstein and i
love both of those guys oh i love both
of those guys yeah it's just a beautiful
art
some of these street graffiti artists
are ridiculous at the work they do
do you have the bazel story with uh mona
lisa or no what
do we do we have it on here three yeah
top of page three all right let's go
through so thousands
are urging bezos true story
thousands are urging bezos to buy and
eat the mona lisa and finally use his
money for good
bro bible okay why hasn't anyone ever
taken a bite of the mona lisa jeff bezos
the world's wealthiest man can afford to
buy it and take a bite it's time he
started putting his money to good use
and doing good
doing things nobody else can the mona
lisa is a 518 year old
uh uh 518 years old that's a long time
to have existed without a single living
soul taking a bite out of the painting
bezos can afford to do that
anything he wants literally anything
that's the premise for this petition
that
uh has picked up thousands of signatures
over the weekend so why shouldn't bezos
with his fortune of 193 billion dollars
buy the painting and take a bite going
to space is stupid there's nothing in
space worth seeing but earth
and you can see earth from here you
could take a hot air balloon
really high if we wanted to according to
fox news an art expert
valued mona lisa at 60.9
billion dollars last year well let me
just let me let me jump in here because
i know you're not a fan of space you
have no interest of going to space
i like space i just don't want to go in
it i have no problem with space it's
sort of like with pets with me i don't
dislike them i just don't want any all
right well you don't have to go
one percent chance so rather than taking
a bite out of the mona lisa by the way i
think this is obviously a a
humorous sort of uh joke of a story to
buy a 60 billion dollar painting and
take a bite here's a better idea it's an
onion story no i don't think so i think
it's
actually that's not absurd that they
wanted to do i think
like you talked about picture of the
young jeff bezos right
the young jeff bezos now he's 50
something years old wants to go to space
i think
if you're gonna do if you're gonna buy
the mona lisa rather than taking a bite
out of the mona lisa which is
i just absurd on the face of it take the
mona lisa
to space with you let's say you spend a
quarter of your wealth yeah
now can you imagine who painted the mona
lisa leonardo da vinci yes
leonardo da vinci you know 500 and
something years later your painting that
you painted
in italy right is now in space
looking down it's the one painting in
space that to me has a little more
brazing that would be actually kind of
cool you could get some good shots of
that
the mona lisa looking out the window
seeing her eyes out
you know when you have i've seen the
mona lisa in person it's a lot smaller
than you would think yeah it's not that
way you know i think the most
interesting aspect of this story is what
the value of the mona lisa would be
i think 61 billion is preposterous i
think that's ridiculous you wouldn't pay
for it
well i just don't think if let's throw
it out there in an open market and
here's what i think it would get i think
if you get
in the billions i think we get over a
billion i'm guessing one to two billion
somewhere in that range it would def
his most expensive painting that
leonardo da vinci ever had was 450
million
okay it was uh uh prince bhatter bin
abdullah of saudi arabia bought it for
450 million
um so that's the most expensive painting
that was the painting it was the
salvador mundi okay and it was jesus in
a blue dress
okay kind of a odd one where his fingers
were making the sign of the cross can
you pull that up so that went for 450
million
i billion and by the way the mona lisa
is owned by the owners
government it's owned by the city it's
in the louvre yeah there it is
that thing went for 450 million saudi
prince
is that crazy the mona lisa is worth 60
billion no no i don't believe it is
that's what that's what a friendship is
well that's what a french government
official said and the french government
owns the mona lisa
here here's a here's the most ironic
part of that i think a five billion
dollar offer would get it
here's the most ironic part of this so
let's say it was valued at 60 billion
60 billion do you know that where that
would put mona lisa
in the world's wealthiest people it
would be number 20 and it would bump
jeff bezos ex-wife mackenzie scott
from the top 20. so the waltons are
number 19.
he might do it just to say mackenzie
you're out mona lisa
my new baby is worth more than jeff
bezos's ex-wife
same amount but she they she's a little
bit i think she's 59
and this is such a billion dollars more
they were the billion dollars more than
it is there
okay so take the take the mona lisa the
space rather than take a bite out of the
mona lisa so yes or no should he do it
or should he not do it so waste of
take mona lisa to space i i don't think
he should do it i thought it was kind of
a lane
would you rather him take it to space or
take a bite out of mona lisa
okay do you have any opinion on what
happened with g7 do you want to go to g7
page seven
happening right now let's do it let's go
to g7
uh let's see here hang on one second
okay here we go g7 uh take away uh
summer takeaways the us is back on top
the queen cut a chord with a sword
and world's leaders uh world leaders
promised one billion dollars
one billion covet 19 doses this is
business insider story
uh let's see how we want to do this
which one do you want to go through
because there's a lot of stories here
just kind of share your thoughts on what
you thought about it i like the thought
on russia
the thought on russia which one is that
just you know how biden is in europe now
right and he talks a good game when he's
in front of these other leaders
just what is he going to do with russia
i just think
putin would dominate him in a one-on-one
meeting that is just
you know you couldn't even measure how
much dominance he would have i think i
think biden's afraid of him
i think he talks a really tough game
when he's not around him but you know we
all agree that cyber security is one of
the biggest issues we face right now
the threats are coming from russia they
are the ones doing it
and what's a company supposed to do
their only option is to pay the ransom
right and get things going again i mean
we don't even know a fraction of the
amount of cyber attacks that are going
on i mean
they said there was like 65 000 last
year man we hear about one every other
week
but they're constantly happening he has
to stand up at some point and address
this with him
and i just don't think he's got the guts
i don't i think because of hunter
he has compromised joe biden in so many
different ways
on a world stage that he's just he's
unable to i don't think he wants to and
i think he's
unable to so i think that is such a
pressing issue that
we'll never get to the bottom of because
he's not going to do anything i think
the the key thing that is happening
um with the g7 um
and it comes down to you talked about
policies and and basically different
perspectives on how things are operating
i think
for sure and this isn't a knock on trump
but his
whole brand was unilateralism america
first i got this i alone can fix this
whereas biden or the democratic party
they are more about
multilateralism they believe in the
power of multiple countries
i.e the g7 the g8 or the g20 working
together in cooperation
to solve big problems we just dealt with
the biggest problem in the last hundred
years
the coronavirus and now there this is
the importance of working with your
allies i think there's a
um a famous to quote my friend kai
over here his hero winston churchill the
only thing worse than fighting
with your allies is fighting without
them right winston churchill
so right now we are we are working with
our allies
uk france japan germany g7 countries
to work together to figure out what the
hell is going on in this world and
coalescing behind an anti-china and even
an anti-russian
uh opposition because at this point the
world needs to unify
against what the hell china did or what
it's doing and make no mistake about it
did you see the interview with um i
believe his name is kier
simmons uh with he interviewed putin a
couple days ago did you see that
interview
he pressed putin pretty hard um
putin would not talk bad about
china at all he's basically saying why
are you trying to make me say bad things
about china
we're working together with china so you
talked about
cyber warfare and ransomware and
everything that's going like that that
is the new modern warfare
and who are the biggest culprits in that
for sure russia for sure china
so i think the world needs to come
together and call out bad actors for
what they are
you know this is the time for
democracies to stand up united states
uk france germany modern-day democracies
to go against authoritarian dictators of
putin and xi who are working together
and this is the world against the bad
actors so i think good things will come
from this g7
and whether you're a a a biden fan
or not you should not be rooting for
putin in this instance
okay root for biden to deal to tell
basically
putin stop [ __ ] with the united
states here or we're going to come after
you i don't think they came out of it
anymore line though there's a lot of
friction between even these seven
leaders as far as what to do with china
i mean that's a that's part of the the
story the the narrative of what happened
at g7 is like behind the closed doors
they weren't agreeing on anything
there is a uh uh he said what did what
did putin say to china says on russia
biden and
uh biden said u.s relations with moscow
have reached a low point
low point what does that mean low point
i mean low point it wasn't low
just a couple of years ago why is it at
a low point and then you follow that up
by saying they're at their lowest point
that they've been in a very very long
time but we don't want conflict with
russia that's what he said well stop
hacking everything and stop putting uh
viruses on everything and maybe we'll
have a better relationship
it's a two-way street like like my mom
used to always say in order to be a
friend
in order to have a friend you need to be
a friend so here we are trying to
have good relations with russia but
everything in the news is
russians russian hackers did this
russian did this russia think
putin is sitting there weighing out
which ally
is more important and necessary to him
china or iran
and if yes he is who is more important
to russia china without even a question
tell me why china versus iran no no i'm
sorry my apologies china versus u.s who
is more important of an ally china or
iran
china or u.s china u.s is not an ally
with russia and they're clearly aligning
with china
i get that but what i'm asking you is is
putin sitting there saying
i better be careful you know because he
doesn't think us is going to be that
powerful
nation as it once was i better start
kind of stepping back and kind of making
sure that my
relationship with china is strong
because they're neighbors they're down
the street
i know so they're neighbors but i better
be better with china than i am with u.s
well he came out and said that he has
working on
relationships with china i mean he came
out which is not denied important to him
do you believe china
without a doubt do you think china's
more important to russia than us is
yeah probably because i don't think he i
think each day that goes by i think the
threat of the us is minimized in his
mind and
he's definitely calculating every
possible move that he could make
that would be my question if i'm him i
would be looking at that
if i'm him wondering which one of those
two relationships it's interesting
yeah i mean even just look at the the
the from the rest of the
uh of the article some of the big things
that the when i talked about
multilateralism these countries and
these western democracies
working together key issues china
vaccines
covid we talked about this global
minimum tax of 15
believe me they're working on that
climate change these are big
issues that major companies major
countries have to work together on you
can't go at these types of things
alone so pat you were getting at the
fact that if he looks at
china as a bigger threat he might soften
on the u.s and look to a line in a few
more ways
no no no just the other way like like if
he sees
china is about to be a bigger threat to
the world and take over u.s
it is more necessary for him to have a
better working relationship with china
than it is with the us
so here's one two you know how in life
you you have kids and you have wife
which relationship matters more to you
i i don't think i should answer that no
no that's actually a real question
i think which relationship is if you
have a wife and kids i mean again i'm
not married no kids but i hear
every single one of my friends basically
say the most important thing
are my kids that's what i hear every
parent say
i can find a new wife if i can find a
new husband i don't i love my kids
i don't this is that the question you're
at you're not what i'm asking is which
one is more important for you to have a
better relationship with
your wife oh your wife your wife your
relationship
you know i'm talking about who it's more
important not who is your
your wife's not your blood but your kid
is your blood but you made the kid with
the wife right so you have to realize
that part of it
but uh you know he's he's weighing out
which relationship's more important
right now to him and i think for the
time being he's probably sitting there
saying we better not go through the
whole process of us always being number
one we kind of us is getting weaker
maybe not as strong as china was
china's getting right now china's making
a lot of progress we may want to kind of
consider being lighter on china than u.s
which is scary because if they're allies
that's it they already are out guys this
is why
this is why i'm banking on india
this is why i believe india is a because
if india
china and russia team up game over
if india china and let's just say
somebody gets elected in india
that hates the us and likes more with
china and russia and their bot
it's over if india gets bought out in
the next 10 years this game over
that's not how it's telling me i'm just
standing yeah that's not happening i
i think there's some commonality here
with democratic countries
and autocratic countries they there's
like-minded thinking
with china and russia and iran and north
korea
they're like-minded thinkers just like
in democratic countries and western
democratic
civilizations united states france
basically europe india included
australia included
there's like-minded thinking there so of
course
putin and she are going to see eye to
eye on things just like a biden and
merkel are going to see eye to eye on
things and macron
so oh good okay sounds good gang we're
doing it again i believe thursday we're
back on yes this thursday we're back on
same time
uh uh i'm gonna be coming in late late
late the night before but we're gonna do
the podcast this thursday as well so be
with us
i know we were off for a week but this
thursday same time 9 a.m we'll be back
on as well take care everybody have a
good one bye bye bye bye